breaking news just in from Atlanta the
police chief just stepping down in the
wake of a deadly officer-involved
shooting and attempted arrest in a
Wendy's parking lot turning to a
struggle over a stun gun ask yourself
how do you think you would do regardless
of what color you are if you snatched a
cop's taser and tried to shoot him with
it most likely you'd be dead
look behind you look look at this [ __ ]
right here you see this man with sharp
Brooks police just brutally murdered a
man right here didn't even give a [ __ ]
you failed me
shortly before my meeting with the
Spencer family a 27 year old man named
Richard Brooks had been killed by police
officers in a Wendy's parking lot
protests erupted which resulted in the
burning of the Wendy's and The
Accidental killing of a young girl due
to a stray bullet
educated you failed me so he parked his
car in his parking lot fell asleep fell
asleep in the car the police got him out
the car asked him some questions and
that [ __ ] went left it wasn't black
people that burned this Wendy's Town who
burned the Wendy's down
it was actually a Caucasian female
girl got killed right now in the park
like we just left on getting the bottom
A little girl got killed that [ __ ] took
a little girl man [ __ ] 12 man
I love Wendy's though y'all got that
good four for four I [ __ ] with that
though rest in peace Rashawn Brooks
Brianna Taylor and everybody we lost
this year the police brutality covid-19
cause my granny had covered she beat it
that [ __ ] is real everybody take care of
themselves more folks might start
joining us right now like we had this
[ __ ] packed in the whole street right
here we go again with this [ __ ]
thank you
so what do you guys want to be when you
grow up basketball star oh
I'm gonna be myself I was 20 20 been so
far for you guys
good in bed at the same time what do you
mean my cousin died
he was just minding his own business
then he got robbed
they pulled out a gun on him then shot
him
four times in the back
okay
that's my woman
see him again I'll just give him
all three of us is worthless which one
are you guys the oldest yeah then we got
to show the kids the same route like
they gotta look up to us within their
generation dating their generation
everybody
really made me think about like how much
free time and also Financial stability
it really takes to show faces the kind
of angry pep rallies that I have been
going to for the past couple months
prior to that
so many Americans primary concern is
just getting by you know they don't have
time to fly to DC
get their Trump gear and just yell about
[ __ ] it's probably not going to happen
it was also hard to believe that just
two miles away from where I interviewed
those kids in the projects was the
Spencer Family household where they live
an absolute fear of reptiles and
Rothschilds stealing everything from
them
I mean they basically live next door to
a segregated housing project where
people's primary concern is making ends
meet and ultimately escaping poverty it
made me wonder if it would ever be
possible to bridge that Gap in
understanding and more importantly how
much power an American president really
has in a four-year term to fix the
country with such dramatic inequality
and let's keep it real poor
informational literacy this is the sign
for a boy lover right here